welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry today's episode
is with david chalmers and explores his
brand new book reality plus virtual
worlds and the problems of philosophy
for those not familiar with david he is
a philosopher and cognitive scientist
who specializes in the philosophy of
mind and language he is a professor of
philosophy and neuroscience at new york
university and is the co-director of
nyu's center for mind brain and
consciousness
professor chalmers is widely known for
his formulation of the hard problem of
consciousness which asks why a physical
state like the state of your brain is
conscious rather than non-conscious
before we jump into the interview we
have some important but bittersweet
changes to this podcast to announce
after a lot of consideration i will be
moving on from my role as host of the fy
podcast and this means two things the
first is that fli is hiring for a new
host for the podcast as host you would
be responsible for the guest selection
interviews production and publication of
the fli podcast if you're interested in
applying for this position keep your eye
on the careers tab on the
futureoflife.org website for more
information
the second is that even though i will no
longer be the host of the fy podcast
i'll still be in the podcasting space
i'm starting a brand new podcast focused
on exploring questions around wisdom
philosophy science and technology where
you'll see some of the same themes we
explore here like existential risk and
ai alignment i'll have more details
about my new podcast soon if you'd like
to stay up to date you can follow me on
twitter at lucasfm perry link in the
description this isn't my final time on
the fy podcast i've got three more
episodes including a special farewell
episode so there's still more to come
i'm really grateful to have gotten the
chance to interview david as one of my
final episodes on the fy podcast it was
a great pleasure connecting with him and
i hope you find this episode enjoyable
and valuable as well
and so with that i'm very happy to
introduce david chalmers on his newest
book reality plus
welcome to the podcast david it's a
really big pleasure to have you here
i've been been looking forward to this
we both love philosophy so i i think
this will be a lot of fun
um and we're here today to discuss your
your newest book uh reality plus
how would you see this as fitting in
with the
longer term project of your career and
philosophy
oh boy um
this book
is all about
reality um
i think of philosophy as being about
to a very large extent about the mind
about the world
and about relationships between the mind
and the world
in a lot of my earlier work i've focused
on the mind i was drawn into philosophy
by the problem of consciousness
understanding how a physical system
could be conscious trying to understand
consciousness in scientific
philosophical terms
um
but you know there are a lot of other
issues in uh
in
philosophy too and as my career has gone
on i guess i've
grown more and more interested in the
world side
of the equation the nature of reality
the nature of the world such that the
mind
can know it um so i guess
you know i wrote a fairly technical book
back in 2010 2012 called constructing
the world that was all about you know
what other
so what is the simplest vocabulary you
can use to uh to describe
reality but um
one thing that uh
was really distinctive to this book was
thinking about it in terms of technology
um you know in philosophy
it's often important to
it often
is interesting and cool to uh
take an old philosophical issue and give
it a technological twist i mean maybe
this is most clear
in the case of thinking about the
mind and then think about the mind
through the lands of ai are artificial
minds possible that's a big question for
anybody if they are maybe that tells us
something interesting about
the human mind if artificial minds
are possible then
maybe the human mind is in relevant ways
analogous for example to an artificial
intelligence
then the same kind of question comes up
for thinking about reality and the world
or artificial worlds possible normally
we think about okay ordinary physical
reality and the mind's relation to that
but um with technology there's now a lot
of impetus to think about artificial
realities realities that we
construct and the crucial
case there is virtual realities
computational
based realities virtual worlds of the
car even of the kind we might construct
say with uh with video games or
full-scale virtual realities full-scale
universe
simulations and then a bunch of
analogous questions
come up um are
artificial realities genuine
realities and just in the artificial
mind case i want to say artificial minds
or genuine minds well likewise in the
artificial world case i want to say yeah
virtual realities are genuine realities
and that's in fact the central slogan of
this new book reality plus which is very
much trying to look at some of these
philosophical issues about reality
through the lens of technology
and virtual realities as well as trying
to get some philosophical insight into
this kind of virtual reality technology
in its own right by thinking about it
philosophically this is the process i
call techno philosophy
using technology to shed light on
philosophy and using philosophy to shed
light on technology
so you mentioned um
of course you're
widely known as a philosopher of
consciousness and it's been a lot of
what you focused on throughout your
career you also described this
transition from being interested in
consciousness to being interested in
the world increasingly over your career
is that fair to say
yeah i mean it's like i've always been
you know you can't be interested in one
of these things without being interested
in the other things i've always been
very interested in in reality and even
in
my first book on consciousness there was
speculation about
the nature of reality maybe i talked
about the it from bit hypothesis there
maybe realities made of information
i talked about quantum mechanics
and potential connections to
consciousness so yeah you can't think
about say the mind body problem without
thinking about bodies as well as minds
you have to think about
physical reality but uh i mean there's
one particular distinctive question
about the nature of reality namely how
much can we know about it
and uh can we know anything about the
external world that's a very traditional
problem in philosophy it goes back to
descartes saying how do you know you're
not dreaming right now or how do you
know you're not being fooled by an evil
demon who's producing sensations as of
an external world
when none of this is real and for a long
time i thought i just didn't have that
much to say about this very big
question in philosophy i mean i think
it's like the problem of consciousness
the the mind body problem that's a
really big question
in the uh the history of philosophy but
to be honest i've got to say it's
probably not number not number one
number one and at least in the western
philosophical tradition is how do we
know anything about the external world
and for a long time i thought i didn't
have anything
to say about that and at a certain point
um
partly through thinking about
virtual realities and the simulation
hypothesis i thought yeah maybe there is
something new
to say here
via this idea that you know virtual
realities are genuine
realities maybe these hypotheses that
descartes put forward saying if this is
the case then none of this is real
maybe descartes was actually thinking
about these
hypotheses wrongly and i actually got
drawn into this around the same time
just totally fortuitously
i got invited to write an article for
the matrix website
a bunch of philosophers were
their production company red pill
uh
there was a guy called a philosopher
called chris growl who worked for them
and i guess
the wachowskis were super interested in
philosophy they wanted to see what
philosophers thought of philosophical
issues coming from the uh from the movie
so i ended up writing an article called
the matrix as metaphysics
putting forward this rough point of view
which is roughly in the context of the
movie that
even in the movie they say if we're in
the matrix none of what we're
experiencing is real all this is
an illusion or a fiction i tried to
argue even if you're in the matrix
these things around you are still
perfectly real there are still trees
there are still
cats there are still chairs there are
still
planets it's just that they're
ultimately
digital but they're still perfectly real
and i tried to use that way of thinking
about the matrix to provide a response
to descartes who's you know the version
of descartes who says we can never know
anything about the external world
because we can't rule out that none of
this is real
all those scenarios descartes
had in mind i think some sense there are
actually scenarios where things are real
and that makes uh
this vision of reality is maybe it makes
reality a bit more like virtual reality
but that vision of reality
actually puts knowledge of the external
world more within our grip so and i
guess and from there there's a clean
path from writing that article 20 years
ago to writing this book now which takes
this idea of virtual reality is genuine
reality and tries to just draw it out in
all kinds of directions to argue for it
to connect to you know
present-day technology
uh to connect it to a bunch of issues in
philosophy and science because if i want
to start thinking this way about reality
at least i've found you know it changes
everything it changes all kinds of
things about
your vision of the world
so i think that gives a really good
taste of uh
what is to come in this interview and
also what's in your book before we dive
more into those specifics
i'm also just curious what your favorite
part of the book is like um if there's
some section or maybe there isn't uh
that you're most excited to talk about
what would that be oh i don't know um i
was gonna say my favorite parts of the
book are the illustrations
amazing illustrations by uh tim peacock
who's uh
a great illustrator who i found out
about
and i asked if he'd be able to do
uh illustrations for the book and he
took so many of these
of these scenarios philosophical thought
experiments science fiction scenarios
and came up with wonderful illustrations
to go along with it so we've got
plato's cave but updated for the 21st
century with uh people in virtual
reality inside plato's cave with mark
zuckerberg running the cave
or uh we have uh an ancient indian
thought experiment
about narada and vishnu updated in the
light of rick and morty we've got a
teenage girl hacker creating a simulated
universe and the in the next universe up
so these illustrations are wonderful but
i guess that doesn't quite answer your
question of which parts do i especially
want to talk about
i guess i think i think of the book as
having roughly two halves there's half
of it is kind of broadly about
the simulation hypothesis the idea that
the universe is a simulation and trying
to use that idea to shed light on all
kinds of
philosophical problems
and the other half
is um
more about real virtual reality you know
the coming actual virtual reality
technology that we have and we'll
develop in the next say 50 to 100 years
and trying to uh to make sense of that
and the issues it brings up so in the
first part of the book i talk about very
abstract issues about
uh knowledge and reality
and the simulation hypothesis but in a
second the second part of the book gets
a bit more down to earth
and
even comes to issues about ethics about
value about political philosophy how
should we set up a virtual world and i
guess over time i've been that was that
was more of a departure for me to be
thinking about
some of those uh
those more practical and political
issues but over time i've come to find
they're fascinating to think about so i
guess i'm actually equally fascinated by
uh
by both sets
um of issues but uh
but i guess lately i've been thinking
especially about um some of these second
class of issues because a lot of people
given you know the coming
all the corporations now are playing up
the metaverse and coming virtual reality
technology that's been
that's been really interesting to think
about
so um
given these two halves in general and
also the way that the book is structured
uh what would you say are your central
claims in this book what is the the
thesis of the book
yeah the thesis of the book uh that i
lay out in the introduction is virtual
reality is genuine reality it's not a
second class reality it's not fake or
fictional
uh virtual reality is real and that kind
of breaks down
into a number of sub theses
one of them is about like you know the
existence of objects and
it's a thesis in metaphysics it says
well
in a virtual the objects in virtual
reality
are real objects a virtual tree or
is a real object it may be a digital
object but it's real or the same it has
causal powers it can affect us it's out
there independently of us it needn't be
an illusion so yeah virtual objects are
real objects what happens in virtual
reality
really happens
that's one kind of uh one kind of thesis
another thesis is about value or meaning
that you can lead a valuable life
you can lead a meaningful life
inside a virtual world some people have
thought that virtual worlds can only
ever be
escapists or fictions or
not quite the real thing i argue that
you can lead a perfectly meaningful life
and the third kind of thesis is tied
closer to the uh the simulation
hypothesis idea and there i argue i
don't argue that we are in fact in a
computer simulation but i do argue that
we can never know that we're not in a
simulation there's no way to exclude the
possibility that we're in
a simulation so that's a hypothesis to
take very seriously
and then i use that hypothesis to
flesh out a number of different just say
we are in a simulation then yeah what
would this mean for say
our knowledge of the world what would
this mean for
for the reality of god what would this
mean for the underlying nature of the
metaphysics underneath physics and so on
and i try and use that to
just uh
put forward a number of sub theses in
each of these domains
so the these claims also seem to line up
with a really core questions in
philosophy
particularly having to do with knowledge
reality and value so could you explain a
little bit like what are some of the
core areas of philosophy and how they
line up with
your exploration of this issue through
this book
yeah i mean traditionally philosophy is
at least sometimes divided up into three
areas metaphysics epistemology and the
theory of value
metaphysics is basically questions about
reality
epistemology is basically questions
about
knowledge
and value theory is questions about
yeah about value about good versus bad
better versus worse
and in the book i kind of divide up
these questions about virtual worlds
into three big questions in each of
these areas which i call the knowledge
question
the
reality question
and the value question
the knowledge question is
uh
can we know
whether we're in a virtual world
yeah in particular can we
can we ever be sure that we're not in a
virtual world and there
i argue for an answer of no we can never
know for sure that we're not in a
virtual world we can never exclude that
possibility but then there's the reality
question which is roughly if we are in a
virtual world is the world around us
real are these objects real are virtual
realities genuine realities or are they
somehow illusions
or fictions and there i argue for the
answer yes
virtual worlds
are real entities and events
in virtual world or perfectly real
entities
and events and even if we're in a
simulation the objects around us are
still real so that's a thesis in
metaphysics
then there's the question in value
theory which is uh
roughly can you lead a good life
in
a virtual world there as i suggested
before i want to argue yes you can lead
a good and meaningful life in a virtual
world so yeah the three big questions
behind the book each
correspond then to a big uh question a
big area of philosophy and i think they
actually i would like to think they
actually illuminate
not just questions about virtual worlds
but
big questions in those areas more
generally the big question of knowledge
is can we know anything about the
external world
the big question of reality is what is
the nature of reality
the big question about value is what is
it to lead a good life those are big
traditional philosophical questions i
think thinking about each of those three
questions through the lent through the
the lens of virtual reality and trying
to answer the more specific questions
about what is the status of knowledge
reality and value in a virtual world
that can actually shed light on those
big questions of philosophy more broadly
so what i try to do is in the book is
often start with the case of the virtual
world give a philosophical analysis of
that and then try to draw out morals
about the big traditional philosophical
question more broadly
sure and this this seems like it's
something you bring up as techno
philosophy in the book where philosophy
is used to inform the use of technology
and then technology is used to
inform philosophy so it's there's kind
of like this mutual beneficial
uh exchange through techno philosophy
yeah philosophy is this two-way
interaction between philosophy and
technology so what i've just been
talking about now
using
virtual reality technology and virtual
worlds to shed light on big traditional
philosophical questions
that's the uh
that's the er the direction in which
technology sheds light on philosophy or
at least thinking philosophically about
technology can shed light on big
traditional questions and philosophy
that weren't cast in terms of technology
you know can we know we're not in a
simulation that sheds light on what we
can know about the world
um can we lead a
uh good life in a virtual world that
shed some light on what it is to lead a
good life
and so on so yeah this is the half of
techno philosophy where thinking about
technology
sheds light on philosophy
the other half is
thinking philosophically using
philosophy to shed light on technology
and just thinking philosophically about
virtual reality technology
simulation technology augmented reality
technology
and so on and that's uh
and that's i think something i really
try to do
um in the book as well and i think these
two things these two processes of course
complement each other because thinking
you think philosophically about
technology it sheds some light on the
technology but then it turns out
actually to have some impact
on the broader issue broader issues of
philosophy at the same time
sure so uh what's coming up for me is uh
plato's cave allegory is actually like a
form of technology of techno philosophy
potentially where like the the candle is
a kind of technology that's being used
to
you know cast shadows to inform how
plato's examining the world
that's interesting yeah i hadn't thought
about that but i suppose back around
plato's time i mean people did did a
whole lot with uh with candles and
fire you know these were very major
technologies of the time and maybe at a
certain point people started developing
puppet technology and started doing
puppet style shows that were
a form of i don't know entertainment
technology for them and then for plato
then to be thinking about the cave in
this way yeah it is a bit of a
technological setup and plato is using
this new uh this new technology to make
claims about reality plato also wrote
about other technologies he wrote about
writing you know the invention of
writing and he was quite down on it he
thought you know or at least his
spokesman's socrates said
you know in the old days people would
remember all the old tales they'd carry
them around in their head and tell them
person to person and
now you can write them down no one has
to remember them anymore and he thought
this was a somehow a step back and the
way in which some people these days
think that you know
putting all this stuff on your
smartphone might be a might be a step
back but yeah plato was very uh very
sensitive to the technologies of the
time
so let's make a b-line for your central
claims in this book uh and just just
before we do that i have kind of a
simple question here for you maybe it's
not so simple uh but so what is virtual
reality
yeah the way i define it in the book i
make a distinction between a virtual
world
and virtual reality
where roughly you know virtual reality
technology is immersive um it's the kind
of thing you experience say with an
oculus quest headset that you uh
that you uh put onto your uh
onto your head
and you experience a three-dimensional
space all around you whereas a virtual
world needn't be immersive when you play
a video game when you're
playing world of warcraft or you're in
fortnite
typically there's just a
there's just you're doing this on a
two-dimensional screen it's not fully
immersive but there's still a computer
generated world
so my definitions are a virtual world
is
an interactive computer generated world
has to be interactive if it's just a
movie then that's not yet a virtual
world but if you can perform actions
within the world and so on and it's
computer generated that's a virtual
world
a virtual reality is an immersive
interactive
computer generated world then with the
extra condition this has to be
experienced you know in
3d with you
at the uh at the center of it typically
these days
experienced with a vr
headset and that's a that's virtual
reality so yeah virtual reality is a
immersive interactive computer generated
reality
so one of the central claims that you
mentioned earlier was that virtual
reality is is genuine genuine reality so
could you begin explaining uh why is it
that you believe that virtual reality is
genuine reality
yeah
because a lot of this depends on what
you mean by uh
by real
and by genuine reality and one thing i
do in the book is trying to break out
different number of different meanings
of real what is it for something to be
real
one is that it has some causal powers
that can make a difference
in the world
one is that it's out there
independent of our minds
it's not just all in the mind
and one maybe the most important is that
it's
not an illusion
it's not just that you know things are
roughly as they seem to be
and i try to argue that if we're in vr
the objects we see have all of these
all of these uh these properties
basically the ideas
when you're in virtual reality you're
interacting with digital objects
objects that exist as data structures on
computers actual concrete processes up
and running
on a computer and we're interacting with
uh
with concrete data structures realized
in circuitry
on these computers and those digital
objects have real causal powers they
make things happen they're when two
objects interact in vr
the two corresponding data structures on
a computer are genuinely
interacting with each other
when an object virtual object appears a
certain way to us that data structure is
at the beginning of a causal chain that
affects our conscious experience in much
the same way that a physical object
might be at the start of a causal chain
affecting our experience
and most importantly
i want to argue that i just say you know
let's take the extreme case of a
i find it useful to start with the
extreme case of the simulation
hypothesis
where all of this
is the simulation um i want to say in
that case when i have an experience of
say a tree in front of me or
um here's a here's a desk and a chair
um i'm gonna say none of that is
illusory there's no uh there's no
illusion there you're interacting with a
uh
with
a digital object
it's a digital table or a digital chair
but it's still perfectly real and what
the way that i end up arguing for this
in the book is to argue that the
simulation hypothesis should be seen as
equivalent to a kind of hypothesis which
has
become familiar
in physics it's a version of the
so-called it from bit
hypothesis
the it from bit hypothesis says roughly
that physical reality is grounded in a
level of
interaction of bits or some
computational process you know the
paradigm illustration here would be
conway's game of life
where you have a cellular automata with
cells that can be on or off and simple
rules governing their interaction and
various people have speculated that the
laws of physics could be grounded in
some kind of algorithmic process perhaps
analogous
to conway's game of life people call
this digital physics
and you know it's not especially widely
believed among physicists but there are
some people who take it seriously and at
least it's a coherent hypothesis that
yeah there's a level of
bits underneath physical objects
in reality and importantly
you know
if the it from bit hypothesis is true
this is not a hypothesis where nothing
is real
it's just a world where there's still
are chairs and tables there still are
atoms and quarks it's just they're made
of bits there's a level underneath the
quarks the level of uh of bits so things
are perfectly real so in the book i try
to argue that actually the simulation
hypothesis is equivalent to this it from
bit hypothesis it's basically if we're
in a simulation yeah there are still
tables and chairs atoms and quarks
there's just a level of bits
underneath that all this is realized
maybe by a computer process involving
the interaction of bits and maybe
there's something underneath that in
turn that leads to what i call the it
from bit from it hypothesis maybe if
we're in a simulation there's a you know
a number of levels
like this
but yeah the key then is the argument
that these two hypotheses are equivalent
which is a
a case i try to make in uh in chapter
nine
of the book um you know the argument
itself is is complex but there's a nice
illustration to uh to illustrate it on
one hand we've got a
traditional god creating the universe by
creating some bits
by uh
by yeah let there be bits uh god says
and lays out the bits and gets them
interacting and then we get tables and
chairs out of that
and in the other world we have a hacker
who does the same thing except via a
computer
uh let there be bets you know arranged
on the uh on the computer and we get uh
we get virtual tables and chairs
out of that i want to argue that you
know like the god creation scenario and
the uh
the hacker simulation scenario are
basically isomorphic
okay uh my i'm being uh
overwhelmed here with uh
all the different uh ways that we could
take this so
one way to come at this is from the
metaphysics of it where we look at kind
of uh causing different cosmological
understandings you talk in your book
about there being this what is the dust
theory
um there may be some kind of like dust
which can implement any number of like
arbitrary algorithms which then you know
potentially above that there are bits
and then uh ordinary reality as we
perceive it is kind of structured and
layered on top of that
and looking at reality in this way
can
help to
you know it gives kind of a
computationalist view of metaphysics and
so also the world which then informs how
we can think about
virtual reality uh and in particular the
the simulation
hypothesis
so um
could you introduce the uh the dust
theory and how that's that's related to
the
it from bit argument
yeah the dust theory is an idea that was
put forward by the australian science
fiction writer greg egan in his book
permutation city which came out in the
mid 90s and is a wonderful
science fiction novel about
computer simulations
i mean the dust theory is a very i mean
is in certain respects even more extreme
than uh than my view i want to say that
as long as you have the right
computation
and the right causal structure
between entities in reality then you'll
get
genuine reality and i argue that can be
present in a physical reality that can
be present in a virtual reality
egan goes a little bit more extreme than
me he says you don't even need this
causal structure
all you need is unstructured dust
i mean we call it dust it's basically a
bunch of entities that have no spatial
properties no temporal properties it's a
whole totally unstructured
set of entities but we think of this as
the dust
and he thinks the dust will actually
generate every computer process
that you can imagine
he thinks they can generate any
objects that you imagine
and any any conscious being that you can
imagine
and so on because he thinks there's ways
of interpreting the dust
so that uh you know it's for example
implementing any computer program
whatsoever and in this respect
egan has actually got some things in
common with philosophers like
the american philosophers hillary putnam
and john sull who argued that
computation is somehow
uh
you can find any computation anywhere
seoul argued that his wall implemented
the uh the word star word processing
program
putnam suggested that maybe a rock could
implement complex
computations basically because you can
always map the parts
of
the computation of the physical object
onto the parts of the computation i
actually disagree with this view i think
it's too unconstrained i think it makes
it too easy for things
for things to be real
um roughly the reason is i think you
need constraints of cause and effect
between
the objects for a bunch of entities in a
rock or a wall
to
implement say a word star they have to
be arranged in a certain way so they go
through certain state transitions
and so they would go through different
state transitions in different
circumstances
to actually implement that algorithm and
that requires genuine causal structure
and yeah way back in the 90s i wrote a
couple of articles
arguing that
the structure you'll find in a you know
a wall or a rock is not enough
to implement
most computer programs i'd say exactly
the same for egan's dust theory that the
dust does not have enough structure to
support a genuine reality because it
doesn't have these patterns of cause and
effect
uh of being counterfactuals like if this
had happened then this would have
happened
and so you just don't get that rich
structure out of the dust so
i want to say that
you can get that structure but to get
that structure you need a
you need you know dust structured by
cause and effect and importantly i think
in an average computer simulation like
the simulation hypothesis it's not like
the dust computer simulations really
have this rich causal structure going on
inside the computer you've got circuits
which are hooked up to each other in the
patterns of cause and effect that are
isomorphic to that in the physical
reality that's why i say virtual
realities are genuine realities because
they actually have this underlying
computational structure
but i would disagree with eagan that the
dust
is a genuine reality because the dust
doesn't have these patterns of cause and
effect i ended up having a bunch of
email with uh with greg egan about this
and he was arguing for his own
particular theory of causation which
went
another way but um
but yeah at least that's where i want to
hold the line cause and effect matters
my questions are so
what is the work then that you see the
dust theory doing in your overall
book in terms of your
arguments for
reality as
sorry for virtual reality is genuine
reality
the dust theory comes relatively late in
the uh in the book right uh earlier on i
talk about bringing in this it from bit
idea
that yeah the whole of reality might be
grounded in information in bits
in computational processes
i see the dust theory as being
with partially tied to a certain
objection
somebody might make but i've made it too
easy
for things to be real now if i can find
reality and a whole bunch of bits
like that maybe i'm going to be able to
find this reality everywhere and even if
we're just connected to dust there'll be
trees and chairs and now isn't reality
made trivial
so so partly i think that's an objection
i want to address when i say no it's
still not trivial to have reality you
need all this structure this kind of
causing this track cause and effect
structure or roughly equivalently a
certain mathematical structure in the
laws of nature
and that's really a substantive
constraint but it's also tries it's also
a way of
helping to motivate
the view that i call structuralism
about and that many others have called
structuralism or structural realism
about
physical reality which i think is kind
of actually the key
to uh to my thesis why does virtual
reality get to count as genuine reality
ah because it has the right structure
it has the right causal structure it has
the right kind of mathematically
characterizable
interactions
between different entities what matters
is not so much what these things are
made of intrinsically about the
interactions and the relations between
them and that's a view that many
philosophers of science these days
find very plausible it goes back to
you know punkaray and
russell and
carnap and others but yeah very popular
these days what matters say for a theory
and physics to be true
is that uh
basically you've got entities with the
right kind of
structure of interactions
between them and if that view is right
then it gives a nice explanation of why
virtual reality it counts as genuine
reality because when you have a computer
simulation of a given physical
uh
of say the physical world that has all
that preserves computer simulation
preserves the relevant kind of structure
so
yeah the structure of the laws of
physics could be found in a physical
reality but it could also that structure
can also be found in a computer
simulation
of that reality computer simulations
have the right
structure
but then it's um
yeah so it turns up that's not totally
unconstrained some people think
um yeah egan thought
yeah the dust is good enough some people
think purely mathematical structure is
good enough in fact your sometime boss
max tegmark
i think
may think something like this in his uh
in his book on the mathematical universe
he argues that reality is completely
mathematical at least sometimes
it seems to look as if he's saying the
content of our physical theories
is just purely mathematical claims
that you know there exists certain
entities with a certain mathematical
structure
and i worry i worry that as with egan
that if you understand the content of
our theories is purely mathematical
then you'll find that structure anywhere
you'll find it in the dust you'll find
it in any abstract of mathematics and
there's a worry that actually
our physical theories could be
trivialized
and they could all end up being true
because we can always find
dust or mathematical entities with the
right structure but i think if you add
the constraint of cause and effect
here then it's no longer it's no longer
trivialized so i think of yeah egan and
tegmark is potentially embracing
a kind of structuralism which is uh
which is know even broader than mine
lets in even more kinds of things as
reality and i don't want to be quite so
unconstrained so i want to add some of
these constraints of uh
of cause and effect so that was so this
is yeah rather late in the book this is
kind of articulating this the nature of
the kind of structuralism that i see is
underlying this view of reality
so so so egan and max might be letting
in uh entities into the category of what
is real which might not have causal
force and so
you know you're adopting this criteria
of cause and effect being important and
structuralism for what counts as genuine
yeah i worry that if we don't at least
have um i think cause and effect is very
important to our ordinary conception of
reality that for example things have
causal powers
if we don't have some kind of causal
constraint
on reality then it becomes almost
trivial to
interpret you know reality as being
anywhere so i guess i think of
you know what we mean by real is partly
a verbal question but i think of
causal powers is very uh
is very central
to our ordinary notion of reality and i
think that manages actually to give us a
highly constrained notion of reality
where you know
realities are at least partly
individuated by their causal structures
but where
it's not how it's not now so
broad that you know arbitrary
conglomerates of dust get to count as uh
as being on a power with our physical
world or arbitrary sets of mathematical
entities likewise let's talk more about
the criteria for what
makes things count as real or genuine or
whether or not they exist you spend a
lot of time on this in your in your book
sort of setting up and then arguing for
different positions on
whether or not certain
criteria are necessary and or sufficient
for um satisfying some understanding of
uh like what is real or what is it that
it means that something exists or that
it's genuine
um and this is you know really important
for your central thesis of
virtual reality being genuine reality
um
because it's important to know like what
it is that exists and how virtual
reality fits into what is real overall
so um could you explore some of the
criteria for um
what it means for something to be part
of reality or what is reality
yeah i end up discussing five different
notions of
reality of what it is for something
to be real i mean
this kind of goes back to the matrix
where uh
neo says this isn't real and morpheus
says
what is real
how do you define real
that's the question how do you define
real
um and i talk about five main
any number of different things people
have meant by real but
i talk about five main strands in our
conception of reality one very broad one
is something is real just if it exists
anything that exists is real
so if that tree exists it real it's real
if the number two exists it's real i
think that's often what we mean
it's also a little bit unhelpful as a
criterion because it just pushes back
the question
to uh what is it for something
to exist but it's a start
then the second one is the one we've
just been talking about the criterion of
causal powers
this actually goes back to uh one of
plato's dialogue where dialogues where
the eliatic stranger comes in and says
for something to be real it's got to be
able to make a difference
it's got to be able to do something
that's the causal power
criterion so if
um to be real you've got to have
effects some people dispute that that's
necessary
maybe numbers could be real even if they
don't have effects maybe consciousness
could be real
even if it doesn't have effects but it
certainly seems to be a plausible
sufficient condition
so that's causal powers
another one is mind independence
existing independently of the mind
there's this nice slogan from um
from philip k dick
where he said uh reality
something is real
if
when you stop believing in it it doesn't
go away reality is that which when you
stop believing in it it doesn't go away
that's basically to say you know its
existence doesn't depend on our beliefs
some things
such that their existence depends on our
beliefs i don't know the easter bunny or
um
or something but uh
more generally i'd say that
some things have existence that depends
on our minds maybe a mirage
um some water up ahead that basically
depends on there being a certain
conscious experience in my mind but
there are some things out there
independent of my mind that aren't all
in my mind
that don't just depend on my mind and so
it leads to the third criterion
something is real when it doesn't wholly
depend
on our minds it's out there
independently of us now this is a
controversial criterion
um
people think that some things like money
may be real even though it largely
depends on our attitudes towards us
towards money
out treating something as money as part
of what makes it
money and actually uh
in the harry potter books i think it's
dumbledore has a uh
has a slogan that goes the opposite way
of um of philip k dicks at one point
towards the end of the novels dumbledore
says to harry uh
harry says
ah but none of this is real and
this is all just happening inside my
head and dumbledore says something like
just because all this is happening
inside your head harry
why do you think that makes it any less
real
so uh i don't know there is a kind of
mental reality you get from the mind but
anyway i think mind independence is one
important thing that we haven't often
have in mind when we talk about reality
um a fourth one is that
we sometimes talk about genuineness
or authenticity
and one way to get at this is we often
talk about not just whether an object is
real but
whether it's a real something like uh
maybe you have a robot kitten
okay it's a real object
uh yes it's a real object it's a genuine
object with causal powers out there
independently of us but is it a real
kitten
is it a real kitten most people would
say that no a robot kitten maybe it's a
real object but it's not a real kitten
so it's not a genuine authentic kitten
and more generally for any x
we can ask is this a real x
and that's this criterion of genuineness
but then maybe the deepest and most
important criterion for me
is the one of not basically something is
real if it's not an illusion that if
it's roughly the way it seems
to be you know it seems to me that i'm
in this environment there are objects
all around me in space with certain
colors
there's a tree out there and
there's a pond
um
and
roughly i'd say that you know things are
all that's real if things are
if there are things out there roughly as
they seem to be but if all this is an
illusion then those things are not real
um
so
then we say things are real if they're
not an illusion if they're roughly
as they seem to be so one thing i then
do is to try to argue that for the
simulation hypothesis at least if we're
in a simulation
then the objects we perceive are real in
all five of those senses
they have causal powers they can do
things they're out there independently
of our minds they exist
they're genuine that's a real tree
at least by what we mean by tree
and they're not
illusions so five out of five on what i
call the reality checklist
ordinary virtual reality i want to say
gets four out of five
the virtual objects we interact with are
they're still digital objects with
causal powers
out there independently of us
um they exist
um they need them be illusions i argue
that at length that your experiences in
vr needn't be illusions you can
correctly perceive a virtual world
as virtual
but arguably they're not at least uh
they're not at least genuine um maybe
for example the virtual kitten
that you
interact with in vr
okay
it's a virtual kitten but it's not a
genuine kitten any more than the robot
kitten is so maybe virtual tables or not
at least in our ordinary language
genuine tables
virtual kittens are not
genuine kittens
but they're still real objects but maybe
there's some sense in which they fail
one of the five criteria for uh for
reality so i say ordinary virtual
realities at least as we deal with them
now may get to four out of five or
eighty percent
on the reality
checklist it's possible that our
language might evolve over time to
to eventually count you know
virtual chairs as genuine chairs and
virtual kittens as genuine kittens and
then we might be more
vr inclusive in our talk and then maybe
we'd come to regard virtual reality as
five out of five on the checklist but
anyway that's the rough
that's the rough way i end up breaking
breaking down these notions into into at
least five and of course one way to come
back is to say ah you've missed the
crucial notion of reality actually to be
real requires this
um
and vr is not real
in that sense
um i just read a review of the book
where someone said
ah look obviously vr isn't real because
it's not part of the base level of
reality the fundamental outer shell
of reality that's what's real so i guess
this person was
advocating uh yeah to be real you've got
to be part of the base fundamental outer
shell of reality i mean i guess i don't
see why that has to be true i mean isn't
it though
well
yeah yeah it's true that's true so
that's one way to it's not
the digital objects ultimately do exist
in the outer
in the outer shell they're just diverse
they're undivided from the outer shell
they just look like they're just like
can be conceptualized as a secondary
yeah no it is very much continuous with
it i want to say the very least they're
on a par with like
micro universes i mean you know we have
people talk now about say baby universes
growing up in black holes
um inside a larger
universe and people take that seriously
and then we'd still say okay well this
universe is part of this universe and
that part of the universe can be just as
real as the universe as a whole so i
don't think yeah
so i guess i don't think you know being
the whole universe is required
to be real we've got to acknowledge
reality to parts of the world
so we have kind of like a common sense
ontology a common sense view of the
world um and to me it seems like that's
more newtonian feeling
um you know
science evolves and then we get quantum
mechanics and so something you describe
you explore in your book is this
difference between
um
repeat what you call it um
like the conventional view of the world
and then also the manifest and the
scientific image is what you call it um
and part of this manifest image is that
uh
it seems like humans kind of have like
uh like our
common sense ontology is kind of
platonic
how would you describe the
the common sense
view of of of what is real
yeah i talk about
the garden of eden which is our naive
pre-theoretical sense of the world
before we've
started doing uh
doing science and developing a more
sophisticated view i do think we've got
we've got this tendency to think about
reality as like
yeah
billiard balls out there and
solid objects
colored objects
out there in a certain space an absolute
three-dimensional space was one
dimension of time
that's our i think that's the model of
reality we had in the garden of eden so
yeah one of the conceits in the book is
well in the garden of eden things
actually were that way
there were three absolute dimensions of
space and
one dimension of time
objects were rock solid
they were colored the way i marked this
in the book is by capital letters say in
the garden of eden there was capital s
space and capital t time where objects
are capital s solid and capital c
colored they were capital r red and
capital g green and maybe there was
capital g good and bad and
capital f free will and
and so on but then we
developed the scientific view of the
world you know we eat from the the tree
of knowledge
it gives us knowledge of uh of science
and then okay well the world is not
quite
it's not quite like that naive
conception
implied you know there's
no there's four dimensional space time
without an absolute space or time
objects don't seem to have these
primitive colors out there on their
surfaces they just have things like
reflectance properties that reflect
light into a certain way
that affects our experience
in a certain way
uh
nothing is capital s solid
they you know objects are mostly empty
space but they still manage to resist
penetration and then
the right way
so um i think this is the fall from eden
and for many things here we've gone from
capital s space to lower case s space
we've gone from capital s solidity to
lower case s
solidity
and um
one thing that i think goes on here is
that we've moved from kind of a
conception of these things as primitive
yeah primitive space and primitive
colors there's just like redness out
there on the surface of things
what i call yeah primitivism it's rather
to a kind of functionalism where we
understand things in terms of their
effects
yeah to be read now is not to have some
absolute intrinsic quality of redness
but to be such as to affect us to
produce certain experiences you know to
look red um to be solid is not to be
absolutely intrinsically solid but to
interact with other objects in such a
way
that they're um
that they're solid
um
so i think in general this goes along
with moving from a conception of reality
as all these absolute intrinsic
properties out there to a much more
structuralist
conception of reality where what matters
for things being real is the right
patterns of causal interaction
with each other
um
of entities with each other i'm not
saying they're all all all there is to
reality is structure
my own view is that consciousness in
particular is not just reducible to this
kind of abstract structure consciousness
does in fact have some
intrinsic qualities and so on so i do
think
that's important too but i do think in
general
the move from the naive conception to
the scientific conception of reality has
often involved going from these kind of
a conception of these primitive
intrinsic qualities to a more structural
conception of reality
right so
i i imagine that many of the people who
will resist the you know this thesis in
your book that virtual reality is
genuine reality may be coming at it from
[Music]
you know the some of these more common
sense
intuitions about what it means for
something to be real like red is a
property that's intrinsic on the surface
of the thing
um how do you see
your
your book
so are there like common sense
intuitions or misconceptions that you
see your book is
addressing i mean i guess i do think
yeah many people do find it as common
sense that virtual reality is not
full-scale reality first-class reality
it doesn't live up to our ordinary
conception of reality and sometimes i
think they may have in mind this edenic
conception of reality the way it was in
the garden of eden
to which my reply is yeah okay i agree
virtual reality does not have everything
that we had in the garden of eden
conception of reality but neither does
ordinary physical reality even in the
even the kind of physical reality
developed
in light of science it's not the garden
of eden
picture of reality
anymore we've lost absolute space and
absolute
time now we've lost absolute colors and
absolute solidity what we have is now
this complex mathematical structure of
entities interacting at a deep level i
mean yeah the further you look the more
evanescent it gets quantum mechanics is
just this this wave function where
objects don't need to have
determinate positions
and who knows what's going on there
against string theory and other quantum
gravity theories um it looks like space
may not be uh may not be fundamental at
all people have entertained the idea
that time is not
fundamental at all so yeah physical
reality in a way it's um
i'm saying you know
virtual reality is genuine reality but
one way to paraphrase that is virtual
reality is just as real as
physical reality if you want to hear
that by saying well physical reality has
turned out to be more like virtual
reality
then you know i wouldn't necessarily
argue
with that uh physical reality is not the
garden of eden
believable conception of reality anymore
it's this much more evanescent
thing which is partly characterizable by
it's just playing all these having the
right kind of a certain kind of
structure and i think all that we can
find in virtual reality so yeah so one
thing i would do
to this person questioning is to say
what do you think even about physical
reality in light of in light of
the last 100 years or so of science
yeah the that reviewers that reviewers
comments that you mentioned come off to
me as
kind of being infor informed by that
the eden view
yeah i think it's right it's quite
common that yeah
that's really what it is it's our naive
conception of
of reality and what reality is like but
yeah maybe then it's already turned out
that the world is not real in that sense
one thing i'd like to to pivot here into
is exploring value more and so
how do you see
the question of
value
fitting into
uh your book right so there's this other
central thesis here that um
you can live a good life in virtual
reality which seems to go against
people's
common intuitions that you can't right
there's this
survey about whether or not people would
go into experienced machines
and most people wouldn't
yeah you know nozik had this famous case
of the experience machine where your
body is in a tank and you get all these
amazing experiences of being highly
successful when most people say they
wouldn't enter the experience machine i
think of professional philosophers
on a survey we did maybe
15 percent said they would enter and
70 odd percent said they wouldn't and a
few agnostics
the experience machine though and many
people have treated that as a
as a
model for vr in general but i think the
experience machine as nosik described it
is actually different from vr in some
respects one is that
very important respect is that
the experience machine seems to be
scripted
seems to be pre-programmed you go in
there and your life will live out a
script where yeah you get to become
world champion but it wasn't really
anything you did
it's just uh yeah that was just the
script playing itself out so many people
think that's kind of fake that's not
something i actually did it was just
something that happened to me
vr by contrast you go into vr
uh even an ordinary video game you've
still got some degree of free will
you're uh you're to some extent
controlling what happens you go into
second life or fortnight or whatever and
yeah you can basically you've got all
kinds of it's not scripted it's open
it's not pre-programmed it's open-ended
and uh
i think the virtual worlds of the future
will be increasingly open-ended so i
don't think worries about the experience
machine tend to undermine
uh
virtual worlds and more generally i
think i want to argue that yeah virtual
worlds can basically be on a par
with physical worlds especially once
we've recognized that they needn't be
illusions
they needn't be pre-programmed and so on
then
what are they missing i think they've
got
you know you've got what's important to
a good life maybe consciousness the
right kind of subjective experiences
also relationships
very very important but you know i think
in a vr in a multi
yeah certainly at least in a multi-user
vr where many people are connected
that's another thing about the
experience machine it's just you
presumably who's conscious but uh in a
vr with i'm assuming a virtual world
with many conscious beings you can have
relationships
with them and get
you know
the meaning the kind of social meaning
of your life
that way
knowledge and understanding i think you
can come to have all those things in
in vr so basically all the determinants
of a good life it's hard to see what's
in principle missing in vr i mean there
are some
worries maybe if you want
a fully natural life a life which is as
close to nature as possible
vr is not going to do it because it's
going to be removed from
nature but you know
but then many of us live in cities or
spend most of our time indoors and
that's also removed from nature and it's
uh you know it's still
compatible with a meaningful life
there are issues about birth and death
you know which are
at least it's not obvious how
genuine birth and death will
will work at least in near-term virtual
worlds maybe once there's uploading
there'll be birth and death in virtual
worlds if
the relevant creatures are fully virtual
but you might think yeah if virtual
worlds lack birth and death there are
aspects of meaning that they lack so i
don't want to say they're exactly on a
power with physical reality in all
respects
but i'd say that you know virtual
realities can at least have the prime
determinants of a good and meaningful
life it's not to say that
life's in virtual reality going to be
wonderful
they may well be awful just as life in
physic in physical reality could be
awful but my thesis is roughly that at
least the same range
of value from the wonderful to the awful
is possible in virtual reality just as
it is in physical reality
it's it sounds like a lot of people are
uh afraid that they'll be losing out on
some of the important things you get
from natural life if virtual life were
to take over
so what are the important things you
have in mind
uh well uh
you mentioned people want to be able to
accomplish things uh
people want to be a certain sort of
person people want to be in touch with a
deeper reality
i certainly think in vr you can
you can be a certain kind of person very
characteristic you can
with your own
personal traits you can have
transformative experiences and virtual
reality probably you can develop
as a person
you can certainly have achievements in
vr you know people who
live spend a lot of time long term in
worlds like second life certainly have
real achievements
real relationships being in touch with a
deeper reality if by a deeper reality
you mean nature
okay in vr you're somewhat removed from
nature but i think that's
somewhat optional i mean there are in
the short term at least there are things
like you know the role of the body
in existing vr's embodiment is extremely
primitive yeah you've got these avatars
but
our relationship with them is nothing
like our relationship with our
physical body so things like
eating and drinking
sex or just you know physical
companionship
and so on yeah there's not
genuine analogs for those in
existing vr maybe as time goes on
um
those things will become better but i
can imagine people thinking
well i value you know
experiences of my physical body
and you know
real eating and drinking and sex and
companionship and
and so on in physical bodies
but i can also imagine other people
saying well actually in vr now we've got
these in 200 years time people say we've
got these virtual bodies which are
actually amazing can do all that and
give you all those experiences and
much more and hey you should try this
and yeah maybe different people would
prefer different things but i do think
to some ext to some considerable extent
um
thoughts about the body may be
responsible for a fair amount of
resistance to vr
could you talk a little bit about the
different kinds of uh technological
uh
implementations of
virtual reality so whether it be like
uploading or brains connected to virtual
uh realities
yeah well i guess you know right now the
dominant form of
vr well the real the dominant virtual
worlds are not even vr at all of course
the virtual worlds people use the most
now are video game style worlds on uh
typically on desktop or mobile computers
on 2d screens
but uh you know immersive vr is picking
up speed fast with
virtual reality headsets like the uh
like the oculus quest and you know
they're still bulky and somewhat
primitive but they're getting better
every year and they'll gradually get
less bulky and
more primitive with more
more detail better images
and so on but a lot of people think yeah
the other form factor which is
developing fast now
is
the augmented reality form with
something like glasses
um
glasses or transparent headsets that
allow you
to see
the physical world but also project
uh virtual objects among the physical
world maybe it's an image of someone
you're talking to
maybe it's just some information you
need for dealing
uh for dealing with the world maybe it's
a pokemon go creature you're trying to
uh
you're trying to acquire if you're a
digital collection so that's the
augmented reality form factor in glasses
i think i guess a lot of people think
that over the next 10 or 20 years
the augmented and virtual reality form
factors could converge
eventually we'll be able to maybe have a
set of glasses that can project
digital objects into your environment
based on computer processes
and maybe you could dial maybe a slider
which could go all the way down to dial
out the physical world be in a purely
physical virtual world dialed all the
way up to be in a purely physical world
or in between
have
elements of both so maybe
so that's one way the technology
seems to be going in the longer term
um
there's the possibility of bringing in
brain computer interfaces
i mean i think
vr with standard perceptual interfaces
works pretty well
for
vision
and for hearing
you can get pretty good
visual and auditory experiences from vr
headsets but yeah embodiment is much
more
limited um your sense of your own body
but maybe once brain computer interfaces
are possible
then there'll be ways of
getting you know elements these
computational elements to inter
to interact
directly with bits of your brain whether
it's a visual cortex auditory cortex
for uh for vision and hearing or for
for the various aspects of embodied
experience
process processed by the parts of the
brain responsible for for bodily
experience maybe that could eventually
give you more
authentic
bodily experiences
um and then eventually you know bits of
the uh
potentially all kinds of computational
circuitry could come to be embedded with
uh with brain circuitry in terms of
circuitry which is going to be kind of
partly biological and partly digital
and in the long term of course there's
the prospect of uploading which is
uploading the brain entirely
to uh to a digital process
and
um you know maybe once our brains are
are wearing out okay we've replaced some
of them with a silicon circuitry but you
want to live forever upload yourself
completely uh so you're running on
digital circuitry of course this phrases
oh so many philosophical issues will it
still be me will it still be conscious
and so on but then event but assuming
that it is possible to do this and have
conscious beings and
uh with this uh digital
technology then that being could then be
fully continuous
with the uh the rest of the world and
could have um
yeah that would just open up
so much potential for new kinds of
virtual reality combined with new kinds
of cognitive process
uh possibly giving rise to experiences
of the kind we can't now even even
imagine now this is okay this is very
distant future i'm thinking
hundred plus years who knows
um
you belong
well yeah okay so this all does interact
with uh with agi i'm on record as 70
chance of agi within a uh
within a century
so uh maybe maybe that's sped up a bit
so
are you sure
this interacts with ai i'm i'm maybe on
50 years for
50-year
mean
expected value for years until agi and
once we've got agi all this stuff ought
to happen happen pretty fast so
maybe there's a case for uh
saying within a century saying that
within a century is conservative
for uploads
yeah for uploads i think once you've got
agis uploads are uh
presumably uh around the corner
um uploads are around the corner at
least if you if you believe like me that
once you've got agi then you'll have agi
plus and then you'll have agi plus plus
super intelligence and yeah agi plus
plus is not going to have too much
trouble with uh
uploading technology and the like
so so how does consciousness fit in all
this
well one very important question for uh
for uploading is uh is whether
uploads will even be conscious
this is also very relevant to thinking
about the simulation hypothesis because
if computer stimulations of brains are
not conscious
then it looks like we can rule out the
the uh the simulation hypothesis because
we know we're conscious if simulations
couldn't be conscious then we're not
simulations so at least the version of
the simulation hypothesis where we are
part of the simulation could then be
ruled out
now as it happens i believe that
simulations can be conscious and i
believe artificial i believe
consciousness is independent of
substrate
it doesn't matter whether you're up and
running on biology or on silicon
you're probably going to be conscious um
and you can run these familiar thought
experiments where you replace
say you know neurons by silicon chips
replace biology by digital technology
and i would argue that
consciousness will be preserved so that
means at the very least gradual
uploading where you uh you know upload
your your bits of your brain yes a
neuron at a time
i think that's a pretty plausible way to
preserve consciousness and preserve
identity
um but if i'm wrong about that and i
could be because nobody understands
consciousness
if i'm wrong about that then uh yeah
uploads will not be conscious and these
totally simulated worlds that
people produce could end up being worlds
of zombies
so i mean that's at least something to
uh that's at least something to worry
about um
you know i wouldn't it'd be certainly
risky to uh risky to upload everybody to
uh
to uh to the cloud to digital processes
without i'd i'd like to keep you know
always keep some people anchored in
biology just to make sure just in case
uh
just in case consciousness does does
require biology because it'd be rather
awful future to have a world of uh a lot
of super intelligent but unconscious
zombies
being the only beings that exist
so so i've heard from people who uh
agree with substrate independence
that digital or classical computers
can't be conscious
are you aware of like responses like
that slash do you have a response to
people who agree that consciousness is
substrate independent but the classical
digital computers can't be conscious
because
i'm not sure what the exact view is but
something like there isn't um
the bits don't all know about all the
other bits there's no like integration
um to create like a unified conscious
experience
the version of this i've heard um
i'm most familiar with this comes from
julio tinoni's integrated information
theory
and tanoni and christoph koch have
argued
that yeah classical
uh processes running on classical
computers
that is on von neumann architectures
cannot be conscious roughly because von
neumann architectures have the serial
core
that everything is uh
is run through
and they argue that
this doesn't have the property that
turnoni calls integrated information and
therefore is not conscious now i i'm
very dubious about these arguments i
mean i'm very dubious about a theory
that says
uh this serial bottleneck would
underline would undermine
consciousness i think you know
you could i just think that's all part
of the implementation you could still
have like
um 84 billion simulated neurons
interacting with each other the mere
fact that their interactions are
mediated by a common
cpu
i don't see why that should undermine
the way that should undermine
consciousness but if they're right um
then fine i'd say okay they've just
discovered something about the kind of
functional organization that is required
for consciousness it needs to be a
certain kind of parallel organization as
opposed to this serial
organization and but if so yeah you're
still right still perfectly substrate
independent
so as long as we um we upload ourselves
not to a von neumann simulation but to a
parallel simulation which is i mean
obviously it's going to be the most
powerful and efficient way
to do this
to do this anyway then uploading ought
to be possible i guess another view is
that consciousness could turn out to
require them to rely on quantum
computation
in a certain essential way so a mere
classical computer might not be
conscious whereas quantum computers
could be
if so well that's very interesting but
yeah but i would still imagine that all
that would also be substrate independent
and for uploading them we just need to
to upload ourselves to the right kind of
quantum computer so i think yeah those
points while interesting don't really
provide fundamental obstacles to
uploading with consciousness here
how do you see uh problems in the
philosophy of identity
fitting in here into virtual reality
um
for example like with derek parfitt's
thought experiments
yeah i mean profit had these famous
thought experiments about the
teletransporter like from star trek
where you duplicate your
your body is that still me at the other
end
the uploading cases are
very similar to that in
in certain respects i mean the
teletransporter you've got so many
different cases you've got do you uh is
the original still around then you
create the copy what if you create two
copies
um and so all these come up in the
uploading case too there's
destructive uploading where we destroy
the original but uh create an upload
there's non-destructive uploading
where we keep the original around
um but also make an upload there's
multiple copy uploading and so on so in
certain respects is very much analogous
to the uh the teleporter case i mean the
change is that
we don't duplicate the being
biologically we end up with a with a
silicon isomorph rather than a
biological duplicate
but uh but aside from that
they're very similar so if you think
that silicon isomorph can be just as
conscious as biological beings
yeah maybe the two things
roughly go together and
yeah i mean the same puzzle cases very
much arise i mean prop just say the
first uploads are non-destructive
we stay around and we create uploaded
copies then the tendency is going to be
to regard the uploads as very different
people from the original
if the first uploads are destructive
you make uh
you make copies while destroying the
original maybe there's going to be
more much more of a tendency to regard
the uploads as being
the same person as the original if we
could make multiple uploads all the time
then there'll be a maybe a tendency to
regard uploads as second-class citizens
and so on so yeah the the thought
experiments here are
are uh
complex and wonderful i tend myself to
be somewhat sympathetic with profits
deflationary views of these things which
is there may not be very much absolute
continuity of people
over time
per the very concept of personal
identity may be one of these identic
concepts that we actually persist
through time as absolute
subjects maybe all there are it's just
different people different times that
stand in
there are people at different times that
stand in psychological and memory
and continuity other continuity
relations to each other and maybe that's
all there is to say this kind of gets
closer now to
buddhist style no self
views at least with no identic capital s
self but i'm very unsure about all of
these matters about identity
how would you
how would you upload yourself
oh i think the safest way to do it would
be gradually
um you know replace my my neurons one at
a time by digital circuits if i did it
all at once
destroy the original creator
uploaded copy i would worry that i'd be
gone
i don't know that i just worry about it
a bit more
to remove that wire i do it gradually
and then i'm much less worried that i'd
be gone if i can you know do it a bit of
the time i'm still here
i'm still here i'm still here to do it
with maximum safety maybe i could be
conscious throughout
with a continuous stream of
consciousness
throughout this process and yeah i'm
here watching the uh the operation they
changed my neurons over and
you know
in that case then it really seems to me
as if there's a continuous stream of
consciousness
and continuous stream of consciousness
seems to either
i don't know if it guarantees identity
over time but it seems pretty close to
what we have in ordinary reality
um
you know we're having continuous stream
of consciousness over time seems uh
seems to be the kind of thing that goes
along with what we usually think of as
identity
over time it's not required because we
can fall asleep and i arguably lose
consciousness and wake up and most
people would say we're still the same
person
um but still being continuously
conscious for a period seems about as
good a guarantee as you're going to get
of being the same person so maybe this
would be the
philosophically safest way to upload
is sleeping not an example that uh
breaks that
i'm not saying it's a uh it's a
necessary condition for a personal
identity just a sufficient condition
just plausibly continuous consciousness
is sufficient for identity over time
insofar as there is identity over time
yes probably too strong a condition it
may be you can get identity from much
weaker relations but in order to be as
safe as possible i'm gonna go with the
uh strongest sufficient condition one
neuron at a time
yeah
maybe ten neurons at a time maybe even
call a few columns at a time i don't
know
do you think buddhists that realize no
self would be more willing to upload
i would think so and i would hope so um
i haven't done
systematic systematic polls on this now
i'm thinking i've got to get the data
from the last fill papers survey and
find
views on
uploading which we asked about versus we
didn't ask about you know are you
buddhist but we did ask do you for
example specialize in asian philosophy i
wonder if there could at least be a
correlation between specialization and
asian philosophy and certain views about
uploading you know that'll be
complicated by the fact that this will
also include uh hindu people who very
much believe in an absolute self and
yeah chinese philosophers who have all
kinds of very different views so
maybe it would require some more
fine-grained
survey analysis yeah i love that you do
these surveys um
they're very cool everyone should check
them out it's a really cool way to see
uh
what what what philosophers are thinking
um you know if you weren't doing them we
wouldn't know
yeah go to fullsurvey.org we this latest
survey in 2020 we surveyed about
2 000 odd philosophers from around the
world on 100 different philosophical
questions like god theism or atheism
mind physicalism or non-physicalism and
so on and we actually got data about
what
professional philosophers tend to
believe and you can look at correlations
between questions correlations with area
with gender
with age and so on yeah it's quite
fascinating so go to fillsurvey.org
you'll find the results
so uh descartes plays a major role in
your book uh both
due to his skepticism
about
the external world and whether or not it
is that we know anything about it um and
then there's also the mind body problem
which you explore so
now since we're talking about you know
consciousness
and the self i'm curious if you could
explain how
the mind body problem fits in all this
yeah in a number of ways um you know
questions about the mind are not
front and center in this book but
they're kind of they come up along the
way in many different contexts in the
end i've actually there's a
yeah one at part five of the book has uh
three chapters on different
questions about the mind one of them is
the question we've just been raising uh
could
um ai systems be conscious
uh could uploading lead to a lead to a
conscious being and so on so that's one
chapter
of the book but another one just thinks
about you know mind-body relations in
more ordinary virtual realities you know
one really interesting
fact about you know existing vr systems
is that if you actually look at virtual
worlds they're kind of cartesian
cartesian thought that descartes thought
there's a physical world
that uh
that um
the mind interacts with and the mind is
kind of outside the physical world
but someone interacts with it well you
look at a virtual world yeah virtual
worlds often have their own physics and
their own like algorithmic processes
that govern
the physical processes
in the uh in the virtual world but then
there's this other category of things
users players
people who are using vr
and they are running on processes
totally outside
the virtual world when i enter a vr the
vr has its own physics but i am not
subject to that physics i'm i've got
this mind which is operating totally
outside the virtual world and you can
imagine if somebody grew up in a virtual
world like this
you know if descartes grew up in a
virtual world we've got an illustration
where descartes
uh grows up inside minecraft and gets
into an argument with princess elizabeth
about whether there could be a
whether the mind is outside this
physical world interacting with it
well you know most people think that the
actual descarte was wrong but
if we grew up in vr
descartes would be right
um he'd say yeah
uh the mind is actually something
outside he'd look at the world around
them and say this is subject to its
physics and so well the mind is just not
part of that it's outside all that
exists in another realm and
interacts with it and yeah there's a
perspective from the of the broader
realm which all this looks physical and
continuous but at least from the
perspective of the virtual world it's as
if descartes was right so that's an
interesting
illustration of yeah a cartesian
interactionist dualism where
the mental and the physical
are distinct it shows a way of which
something like that could turn out i
mean could turn out to be true
under certain versions of the simulation
hypothesis say with brains
interacting with simulations
and maybe even is true
of or something isomorphic of it is true
even in ordinary virtual realities and
at least that's
kind of interesting and making sense of
the uh
this mind-body interactionism which is
often viewed as a unscientific or
non-naturalistic idea but here's a
perfectly naturalistic version of
mind-body dualism yeah i i love this
part and also found it surprising for
that reason right because cartesian
dualism it always feels supernatural
um
but here's a natural explanation
one jump one general theme in this book
is that there's a lot of stuff that
feels supernatural
but once you look at it through the lens
of vr
needn't be quite so supernatural it
looks a lot more naturalistic of course
the other example is god
where yeah if your creator or some is
like somebody a programmer in the next
universe up ah suddenly god doesn't look
quite so supernatural
yeah
magic is like using the console in our
reality to run scripts on
the the
the simulators world or something like
that
right so this is naturalistic magic
magic has to obey its own principles too
they're just different principles in the
next universe up clearly it seems your
view is is consciousness is the
foundation of all values is that right
pretty much yeah pretty much um without
consciousness no value i don't want to
say consciousness is all there is to
value there might be
you know other things that matter as
well but i think you probably have to
have consciousness to have value in your
life and then for example relations
between conscious beings relations
between consciousness and the world can
matter
for a value nose experience machine
tends to suggest that consciousness
alone is
not quite enough
you know there's got to be
maybe things like actually achieving
your goals and so on that
that matters as well but i think yeah
consciousness is at the very core
of what matters in value
so
we have virtual worlds and people don't
like them right because they want to
have an interaction with whatever is
like natural or they want to be a
certain kind of person or they want
the people in it to be
implemented and they want them in real
space
things like that so
um part of what makes being in nozick's
experience machine unsatisfactory is
knowing that some of these things aren't
being satisfied
but what if you didn't know that those
things weren't being satisfied
you thought that they were
yeah i guess my intuition is um yeah
that's still bad
so
you know there's there's this famous
case that people have raised just say
your uh
your partner is unfaithful to you but
you really it's really important to you
that
your relationship be monogamous
um however
your partnership your partner although
professing monogamy has gone off and had
relationships with all these
other people
you never know and you're very happy
about this and you go to your death uh
without ever knowing
i think most people's intuition is that
is bad that life is not as good as one
where the life was the way this person
wanted it to be
with the monogamous partner
um so that kind of brings out i think
that yeah having your goals or your
desires satisfied you know the world
being the way you want it to be that
matters to how good and meaningful a
life is and likewise i'd say that
i think it is really the experience
machine is a more extreme example of
that yeah we really want to be doing
these things if i was to find out
a hundred years later that
hey any success i'd had in philosophy
wasn't because i wrote good books it's
just because uh
yeah there was a bunch there was a
script that said there'd be
certain amounts of success and sales and
whatever then boy that would render
any meaning i'd gotten out of my life
perfectly hollow
so and likewise like even if i never
discovered this if i had the experience
of having this successful life but it
was all merely pre-programmed then i
think that would render my life yeah
much less
less it can still be meaningful but just
much less good than i thought it had
been so that kind of brings out that the
goodness or the value
of one's life depends on more than just
how one experiences things to be
i guess i'm kind of pushing on
consequentialist or utilitarian
sensibilities here who might
bite the bullet right and say that you
know if you didn't know any of those
things and those worlds are still
okay one thing that you mentioned in
your book is that
your belief that virtual reality is good
is independent of
the moral theory that
one has could you unpack that a bit
i don't know if it's totally independent
um
but i certainly think that my view here
is totally consistent with
consequentialism and utilitarianism that
says what matters in moral decision
making is maximizing good consequences
or maximizing utility
now if you go on to identify the
relevant good consequences
with
conscious states like maximizing
pleasure or if you say all there is to
utility is the amount of pleasure
then you would take a different view of
the experience machine
if you thought that all that there is to
uh utility is pleasure that you say in
the experience machine i have the right
amount of pleasure so that's good enough
but i think that's going well beyond
consequentialism
that's uh or even utilitarianism that's
adding a very specific view
of utility and is the one that the
founders of utilitarianism had
like bentham and mill but i think you
know it's easy to i would just advocate
a broader view of of
consequentialism or utilitarianism where
yeah there are kinds of values that go
beyond
value deriving from pleasure or from
conscious experience for example one
source of value is having your desires
satisfied or achieving your goals
i think that's perfectly consistent with
with utilitarianism but yeah maybe
more consistent with some forms
than others
is is having your values satisfied or
your preference satisfied not just like
another uh conscious state i don't think
so because you could have two people who
go through exactly the same series of
conscious states
but for one of whom their desires are
satisfied
and for the other one their desires are
not satisfied maybe they both think
their desires are satisfied
but one of them is wrong you know one of
them wants they both want their partners
to be monogamous
one partner is monogamous and the other
one is not they might have exactly the
same conscious states
but one has in one
the world is the way they want it to be
and the other one the world is not the
way they want it to be
so if desire this is what music argued
and others have argued in light of the
experience machine
is that yeah there's a kind of value in
maybe in desire satisfaction that goes
beyond the value
of consciousness per se i should say
both of these views even the
pleasure-centric view are
totally consistent with my general view
of vr if someone says all that matters
is experiences
well in a certain sense great that makes
it even easier to lead a good life in vr
but but um but i think if the dialectic
is the other way around if even if
someone rejects
that view say there's more than i tend
to believe there's more than matter more
that matters than just consciousness
even if you say that you can still have
a good life in a
in a virtual world i mean there'll be
some moral views where you can't just so
you've got a biocentric view of what
makes a life good
uh you've got to have somehow the right
interactions with real biology
um
i don't know then
maybe certain virtual worlds won't count
as having the right kind of biology and
then they won't count as valuable so i
wouldn't say these issues are totally
independent
of each other
but i do think on plausible moral
theories
um
yeah very much going to be consistent
with
being able to have a good life in
virtual worlds what does a really good
life in a virtual world look like to you
oh boy um
you know i think
what does a really good life
look like to me i mean different people
have
different values but um
i would say i get value from
partly from personal relationships
from you know
uh
getting to know people by
having close relationship with uh
ships with my family with
partners with friends
with colleagues
i get a lot of value from understanding
things
from knowledge and understanding
i get some value from having you know
remarkable having new experiences and so
on and i guess i'd be inclined to think
that in a virtual world the same things
would apply i'd still get value from
relationships with people i'd still get
value from knowledge
and understanding
i'd still get what value from new kinds
of experience
now there may ways in which vr might
allow this to go beyond
what was possible outside vr maybe for
example there'll be wholly new forms of
experience that go way beyond
what was possible inside physical
reality and maybe that would
allow for a life which is better and
in some
respects maybe it'll be possible to have
who knows what kind of telepathic
experiences with other people that give
you even closer relationships that are
somehow
amazing
maybe it'll allow immortality where you
can go on having these wonderful
experiences for an indefinite amount of
time and that could be a
and that could be better i guess in the
short term i think yeah the kind of good
experiences i'll have in vr are very
much continuous
with the good experiences i'll have
elsewhere i want to yep it's a way of
you know i meet friends sometimes in vr
interact with them
talk with them
sometimes play games
sometimes communicate maybe occasionally
have a
have a philosophy lecture or a
conference then so right now yeah what's
good about vr is pretty much continuous
with
a lot of what's good about physical
reality but yeah in the long term there
may be ways for it to go beyond
what's been your favorite vr experience
so far
oh boy everything is uh everything is
fairly primitive for now i enjoy a bunch
of vr games and i enjoy
you know hanging out with uh with
friends one one enjoyable experience was
i gave a little lecture about vr in vr
to a group of philosopher friends
and we were trying to figure out the
physics of a vr
of the particular virtual world we were
in which was on an app called big screen
yeah
and uh yeah you do things in bixby like
you throw tomatoes
and what happens and they behave in
weird ways they don't they kind of obey
the laws of physics but they kind of
don't and the avatars have their own
ways of moving so we were trying to
figure out the basic laws of big screen
and uh
we didn't get all that far but we
figured out a uh we figured out a few
things we were doing science insider
inside a virtual world and you know
presumably if we'd kept going we could
have uh we could have gotten a whole lot
further and got gotten further to the
into the depths of what the algorithms
really are that generate this uh this
virtual world or that might have
required a scientific revolution or two
so i guess that was a little instance of
doing a bit of science inside the
virtual world and trying to come to some
kind of understanding and it was at
least a
very engaging experience
have you ever played any horror games
not really no i'm not much of a gamer to
be honest um you know i play some simple
games like you know beat saber or
what is it a super hot but um
that's not really a horror game it's a
super assassins come after you but
what's your favorite horror game
i was just thinking of my favorite
experience it was probably well i played
killing floor once when i first got the
vr and um it was uh
probably the most frightening experience
of my life like the first time you turn
around and there's like um you know
embodied thing that feels like it's
right in your face
very interesting
in terms of consciousness and ethics and
value
we can explore things like moral
patiency and moral agency so
what is your view on
the moral status of
simulated people
you know my own view is that uh
the main thing the biggest thing that
matters for moral status is
consciousness so as long as simulated
beings are conscious as we are
then
they matter now maybe that you know
current non-player characters of the
kind you find in video games and so on
are basically run by very simple
algorithms
and most people would think that you
know those beings are not conscious
so in which case their lives don't
matter in which case it's okay to
shoot these
currents
npcs in video games i mean maybe we're
wrong about that and maybe they have
some degree of consciousness
and we have to worry but uh
at least the uh the orthodox view here
would be that they're not and even on a
view that describes them consciousness
is probably a very simple form of
consciousness but if we look now to a
long-term future where there are
you know simulations of brains and
agis
and simulated
agis inside
these simulated worlds with capacities
equivalent to our own i'd be inclined to
think that
these beings are going to be conscious
like us and if they're conscious like us
then i think they matter morally
the way that uh the way that we do is in
which case one should certainly not be
indiscriminately killing
uh
simulated beings just because it's
convenient or just indiscriminately
creating them and
and turning them off so i guess if we do
get to the point where
i mean this applies inside and outside
simulations i think we have robot style
agis
that are conscious then they have moral
status like ours if we have simulation
style agis inhabiting simulations they
also have um
have moral status much like ours now it
may be hard for i'm sure
there's going to be a long and
complicated path to actually
keep that playing out in social and
legal context and there may be all kinds
of resistance
to uh to granting
simulations you know legal rights
social status and so on but
philosophically i guess i think that
yeah if they're conscious like us they
they have a moral status like ours
do you think that there will be
simulated agents with moral status that
are not
conscious for example like they could at
least be moral agents
and not be conscious
but
in sort of a society and culture of
simulated things
like
do you think that there would be
cases where things that are sufficiently
complex yet not conscious would still be
traded with moral
patiency
it's interesting i'm inclined to think
that any system that has you know
human level behavior is likely to be
conscious
i'm not sure that there are going to be
you know the cases of zombies where you
lack consciousness entirely but behave
in extremely sophisticated ways just
like us but i might be wrong just say
tony and
right and that
no being running on a von neumann
architecture is conscious
then yeah then it might be uh might be
smart to develop those systems because
they won't have moral status but they'll
still be able to do a lot of useful
things
but yeah would they still then be moral
agents well yeah presumably these
behaviorally equivalent systems could
do things that look a lot like making
moral decisions
even though they're not conscious
would they be genuine agents if they're
not conscious that may be partly a
verbal matter
but they would do things that at least
look a lot like agency and making moral
decisions so they'd at least be moral
quasi agents
then it's interesting question whether
they should be moral patients too
if you've got a super zombie system
making moral decisions does it deserve
some moral respect
i don't know i mean i'm not convinced
that consciousness is the only thing
that matters morally
it may be that for example intelligence
or
planning or reasoning kind of carries
some weight independent of consciousness
if that's the case then maybe
these beings that are not conscious
could still have
some kind of moral status as moral
patience that is as
deserving to be treated well as well as
just moral agents as well as just
performing moral
action
um
maybe it would be a kind of second class
moral patiency certainly
if the choice was between say killing
and being like that and killing an
equivalent conscious being i'd say yeah
kill the unconscious one
but uh that's not to say they have no
moral status then
so one of your theses that i'd like to
to hit on here as well was that we can
never know that we're not in a
simulation
could you unpack this a bit
yeah well this is
you know very closely connected to these
traditional questions in epistemology
can you know you're not dreaming now
could you know that you're not being
fooled by an evil demon now the modern
tech version is can you know you're not
in a simulation could you ever prove
you're not in a simulation and there's
various things people might say oh i'm
not in a simulation i mean naively
this can't be a simulation because uh
look at my wonderful kitten here
that could never be simulated it's so
amazing but
you know presumably there could be
simulated kittens so that's not a uh
not a decisive argument
more generally i'm inclined to think
that for any evidence
anyone could come up with it's allegedly
proof that we're not in a simulation
that evidence could be simulated and the
same experience
could be generated inside a simulated
world
so it starts to look like there's
nothing there's no piece of evidence
that could ever decisively prove we're
not in a simulation and the basic point
is just that
a perfect simulation would be
indistinguishable
from the world it's the simulation of
if that's the case awfully hard to see
how
we could prove that we're not in a
simulation maybe we could get evidence
that we are in a simulation you know
maybe the simulators could reveal
themselves to us and show us the source
code i don't know maybe we could stress
test the simulation by running a really
intense computer process more advanced
than anything before suddenly and maybe
it stresses out the simulation and leads
to a
a bug or a
or something maybe there are ways we
could get evidence maybe we don't want
to do that
yeah okay and maybe they'll get no
that'll
yeah okay
yeah maybe not a good idea but um
so there are various ways we could get
evidence that we are in a simulation at
least in an imperfect simulation but i
don't think we can ever get the uh
evidence in the negative that fully
proves that we're not in a simulation we
can try and test for various imperfect
simulation hypotheses but if we get just
ordinary the expected results then it's
always going to be consistent with both
and they're various philosophers who
tried to say ah there are things we
could do
uh to refute this idea maybe it's
meaningless
maybe um
we can rule it out by being the simple
the non-simulation hypothesis being the
simpler hypothesis and so on so in the
book i try and argue none of those
things work either
and furthermore once you think about the
bostrom style simulation argument that
that says
it may be actually
quite likely that we're in a simulation
because most populations are likely it
seems pretty reasonable to think that
most intelligent populations will
develop simulation technology
once you start thinking that way
i think it makes it even harder to
refute the simulation hypothesis because
uh basically because by this point
you know these simulation style
hypotheses used to be science fiction
cases very distant from
anything we have reason direct reason to
believe in but as the technology is
developing these simulation style
hypotheses become realistic hypotheses
you know ones which is actually very
light
good reason to think are actually likely
to be developed both in our world and in
and in other words and i think that
actually makes these that's had the
effect of making these cartesian
scenarios
um move from the status of science
fiction
to being kind of live hypotheses and i
think that makes them even harder to
refute i mean you can make the abstract
point that we can never prove it without
the modern technology but i think once
they actually exist once this technology
is an existing technology
it becomes all the harder to
epistemologically dismiss
you give some credences in your book um
for whether or not we live in a
simulation could you offer those no
yeah i mean of course anything like this
is extremely speculative but
basically in the book i argue that
if
there are many
conscious human-like
simulations and we're probably
simulations ourselves and then the
question is are there
is it likely that there are many
conscious human-like
simulations and there's a couple of ways
that could fail first it could turn out
that
stimulating beings like us or universes
like ours is not even possible
um maybe the physics is uncomputable
maybe consciousness is
uncomputable so maybe conscious
human-like stimulations like ours could
be impossible
that's one way this could fail to happen
that's what i call a sim blocker
these are things that would block these
simulations from existing
so one class of sim blockers is yeah
simulations like this are impossible but
i don't think that's more than 50 likely
i'm actually more than 50 confident
that simulations like this are possible
the other class of sim blockers
is
or maybe simulations like this are
possible but for various reasons they'll
never be developed or not many of them
will be developed
and this
class of symbolockers includes the ones
that bostrom focuses on
um for example i think there's two of
them um
either will
go extinct before we get to that level
of technology where we can create
simulations or we'll get there but we'll
choose never to create them
our intelligent civilizations will
choose never to create them
and that's the other way
this can uh
this can go wrong is yeah well these
things are possible but
not many of them will ever be created
and i basically say well if
these are possible
and if
if they're possible they'll be create
many of them will be created then many
of them will be created and we'll get a
higher probability we're in a simulation
but then i think okay so what are the
probabilities of each of those two
premises
that conscious human-like
simulations are possible yeah
i think that's at least 50 percent
furthermore
yes um
if they're possible will they be will
many of them be created i don't know i
don't know what the numbers are here but
i guess i'm inclined to think
uh
probably my subjective credence is over
50 in that too given that it just
requires some civilization to eventually
create
a whole lot of them
okay so 50 chance of premise one 50
chance of premise two let's assume
they're roughly independent of each
other
um that gives us a 25 chance they're
both true
if there's a 25 if they're both true
then most beings are simulations
if most beings are simulations then
we're probably simulations putting all
that together
i get roughly at least 25
that we're in a simulation
now there's a lot of room for the
numbers to go wrong
but yeah to me that's at least very good
reason to a to take the hypothesis
seriously and b just suggest if it's at
25 we certainly cannot rule it out
so
that gives a kind of a quasi-numerical
argument that we're not
that we can never know that we're not in
a simulation
like one interesting part that seems to
feed into the simulation argument is
modern work on
quantum physics
so we had yoshibak on
who talked some about this
um
and i don't know very much about it but
there is this debate
over whether
uh
like the universe uh is implemented
in
uh continuous numbers or non-continuous
numbers
and if the numbers were continuous then
um
the universe wouldn't be computable
is that right
i'm not quite sure which which debate
you have in mind but yeah it certainly
is right that uh if the universe is
maximally is like doing real real valued
computation then real value computations
can only be approximated on finite
computers
right on digital computers
right so could you explain how this
inquiry into
um how our fundamental physics works
informs
whether or not our simulation would be
computable
i mean this is there's many aspects of
that
question one thing that um
some people have actually looked into uh
whether
our world might involve some
approximations
some shortcuts so uh zory davoodi and
some other
physicists have uh
have tried to look at the math and say
okay just say just say our simulation
there was a simulation that took certain
shortcuts how would that show up
empirically
and this is this is okay this is going
to be an empirical test for whether
there are
shortcuts in the way our physics is
implemented i don't think anyone's
actually found that evidence here but ah
there's some principle evidence we could
get
of uh
of that
but um
there is the question of whether our
world is fundamentally analog or digital
and if our world is fundamentally analog
you know with
perfectly
precise continuous real values making a
difference to how the universe evolves
yeah then that can never be perfectly
simulated
on a finite digital
computer i would still say it can be
approximated
so and as far as we know we could be
living in a finite approximation to one
of those continuous worlds but yeah
maybe there could eventually be some
empirical evidence of that of course the
other possibilities were just running on
an analog computer if our physics is
continuous then the physics of the next
world app is continuous
maybe there will be analog computers
developed with maximally continuous
uh quantities and we could be running on
an analog computer
like that so i think even if our even if
the physics of our world turns out to be
turns out to be perfectly analog and
continuous that doesn't rule out
the simulation hypothesis it just means
we're running on a
on an analog computer in the next
universe up
okay i'm way above my my pay grade here
um i'm just recalling now i'm just
thinking of how yosho was talking that
um you know continuous numbers aren't
computable right so you would need an
analog computer uh i don't know anything
about
analog computers
um
this seems to me like
it's hard to program analog computers
because they require infinite precision
you know and we find out beings they're
not good at
building things with infinite precision
but we could always just like set the uh
you know set a few starting values
randomly and let the analog computation
go from there
and as far as i can tell there's no
evidence there's no evidence that we're
not living in a
living in a simulation that's running on
an analog computer like that
i see so if we if we discover
our fundamental physics to be
digital or analog
it seems like that wouldn't
tell us a lot about the simulation just
that
the thing that's similar simulating us
might be
digital or analog
in general discovering things about our
i mean the relationship between the
physics of our world and the physics of
the simulating world is fairly weak
especially if you believe in universal
computation you know any classical
algorithm can be uh implemented in
a vast variety of computers running on a
vast variety of physics but yeah but
there might be some limits for example
if
our world has a purely has a perfectly
analog physics that cannot be simulated
on a finite digital computer could be
simulated on an infinite digital
computer you can simulate uh
analog quantities with infinite strings
of bits but not on a finite
digital computer so yeah discovering
that our physics is digital
would uh be consistent with the next
universe up being digital but also
consistent with it being analog analog
computers can analog worlds can still
run
digital computers i mean it'd be very
suggestive if we did actually discover
digital physics in our world i'm sure if
we
discovered that our physics is digital
that would then
get a lot of people thinking hey
this is put this is just the kind of
thing you would expect if people are
running a digital computer in the next
universe up and that might incline
people to take the simulation hypothesis
more seriously but it wouldn't really be
um
be any kind of demonstration
and if we somehow discover that our
physics is perfectly analog i don't
really know
exactly how we could discover that
because
you know at any given point we'll only
have a finite amount of evidence which
will always be consistent with just it
being a very close approximation but
just say we could discover that our
world
runs analog physics yeah then that would
be inconsistent
with this just being a
digital
simulation in the next universe up but
still quite consistent with it being a
simulation running on a analog computer
in the next universe up
i don't know how that connects to
yoshi's
uh way of thinking about this yeah i'm
not sure i'd love to consistently
um has he written about this somewhere
uh
i'm not sure um
there are lots of podcasts uh have been
talking about it though
um okay cool yeah
um
so
we've gone over a lot here and um
it leaves me um not really uh trusting
my common sense experience of the world
so
pivoting a little bit here back into the
the edenic uh view of things
sorry if i get this
the word that you use wrong but it seems
like you walk away from that
with a view of imperfect realism is that
right
yeah imperfect realism is like the
perfect thing capital s solidity doesn't
exist but the lower case thing small
solidity does exist an imperfect analog
of what we initially believed in
so
how do you see the world
now
any any differently um what is what is
the world like to david chalmers
after having written this book what is
what is a person to you
i don't know i mean i think there's your
everyday attitude towards the world and
your theoretical attitude
towards the world and i find my everyday
attitude towards the world doesn't
affect it that much by uh
by deep by
discoveries in philosophy or in science
for that matter we mostly live in the
manifest image maybe even treat it a
little bit like the garden of eden
and that's fine but then there's this
knowledge of what underlies it or what
could underlie it and that's yeah once
you start thinking philosophically that
gets kind of mind-boggling i mean you
don't need to go to the simulation
hypothesis to get or to virtual worlds
to get that reaction i mean quantum
mechanics is quite enough
um oh my god do we live in this world of
the quantum wave function but nothing
actually has these direct positions and
possibly the wave functions collapsing
or possibly
many worlds it's something but it's just
mind-boggling and it is rather hard to
integrate ordinary
life in reality so i think most of us
just kind of go on living in the
manifest image
yeah so once i start thinking about
yeah could we be in a uh a simulation
it's got a similar kind of um
of separateness i guess mostly i go on
living in the
manifest image and don't uh
and don't factor this in but uh i mean
it does open up all kinds of
all kinds of possibilities once you
start thinking that there is maybe this
reality plus of all these different
levels of reality like could it be that
someday it might be possible to escape
this particular virtual world or maybe
when we die
um does our code get uh sometimes get
uploaded by simulators to uh to go hang
out
back in um
back in other levels of reality maybe
there are naturalized versions of
reincarnation or life after death and i
don't want to say this is why i'm
thinking about this stuff it's not for
these quasi-religious reasons but
suddenly you know possibilities that it
seemed very far out possibilities to me
like uh
life after death at least come to seem
like a little bit a little bit closer um
and you know
more like open possibilities and they'd
seemed
seen before so that's at least uh
that's at least interesting
one thing you bring up a bit in your
exploration here is is god and yeah so
and all these things that you're
mentioning you know they seem kind of
like
science coming back science and
philosophy coming back to traditionally
religious ideas but through a
naturalistic
exploration
um
which is quite interesting so do you
have any different thoughts on on god
after having written this book
uh it's interesting you know i'm not
remotely religious myself i've always
thought of myself as an atheist but
yeah after writing this book i'm at
least
it was a version of god that i could at
least take seriously this is the
simulator
they did after all create the world
this world
they may have a lot of power and a lot
of knowledge of this world as gods are
meant to have on the other hand they're
quite unlike traditional gods in some
ways the simulator didn't be all good
needn't be particularly wise or also
didn't create all of reality just
created a little bit of reality maybe
it's a bit like what's sometimes called
the demiurge
uh the the god the local god the
the you know the underboss god who
created this world but wasn't the one in
charge of the whole thing so yeah maybe
simulators are a bit more like demiurges
um
more importantly i think i don't think
i'd be inclined to erect a religion
around the simulation idea you know
religions come with like ethical
practices and
uh really changing your way of life i
don't
think there's any particular reason to
orient our ethics to a uh to a
simulation i mean maybe you can imagine
there'd be some practices that if we
really believed we were in a simulation
or there's a good chance of that we
should at least
start doing some things
differently you know maybe
some people might want to try and
attract the attention of the simulators
i don't know that's all very speculative
so i don't find myself i think the one
moral of all this for me is that
actually you know ethics and meaning and
so on
actually you don't get your ethics or
your meaning from who created you or
from whether it's a god or a simulator
ethics and meaning comes from within it
comes from ourselves our consciousness
and our interactions
do you
[Music]
take a line that's similar to peter
singer and thinking that that is kind of
like an objective rational space are you
a a moral realist or anti-realist about
those things
we tend towards moral anti-realism but
i'm not sure i find those issues very
difficult yeah i can get in the mood
where
pain is bad just seems like an absolute
fact yeah that's just an objective fact
pain is objectively bad and then i get
to at least to some kind of value
realism
if not
moral realism so some moods all go that
way other moods it's just yeah it's all
a matter of our attitude towards it
um
finally it's a matter of what we value
if somebody valued
valued pain it would be good for them
if they didn't
it wouldn't be and i can go i can go
back and forth i don't have a fixed view
of these matters
are there any questions that i haven't
asked you that you would have liked me
to ask you
not especially um you asked a lot a lot
of great questions and there are a
million others but actually one
interesting thing with this book coming
out is getting to do a few of these
having a few of these conversations and
seeing all the different
questions and different aspects of the
book that different people
focused on so i think you've you've
we've covered a lot of territory here
and yeah these are political things to
think about well i'm mindful of the time
here david thank you so much for for all
of your time um if people want to check
you out
uh follow you um and get your new book
where the best places to to do that
probably my website which is uh
conch.net come to the first five letters
of consciousness or just search for
do a search for my name
and then yeah the book is i've got i've
got a page for the book on my website
consciousness
reality or just search for the name of
the book
uh reality plus i'm not on twitter or
instagram or any of those things
unfortunately maybe
maybe i should be one of these days but
uh for now for now i'm not
but uh yeah uh the book will be
available january 25th i guess at uh all
good uh all good booksellers so i hope
some of your listeners might be
interested to to check it out all right
we'll include links to
all those places in the description of
wherever you might be listening or
watching uh thank you so much david it's
it's always a pleasure speaking with you
i love hearing about your ideas and um
it's really a great book at a
important time i think just before
all this vr stuff's about to really kick
off and with the launch of the metaverse
it's uh really well timed oh thanks
lucas this was all yeah a lot of fun to
talk about this stuff with you
[Music]